[Musique]
j'ai voulu vraiment essayé de de
comprendre un petit peu le milieu de
savoir sur quel type de stratégie je
voulais je voulais me lancer
le recrutement la planification dans le
temps voilà de mes objectifs
donc ouais basculer complètement à 2 en
2006 2006 complètement dans cette
profession là donc ça va faire 11 ans
l'ouverture de la société c'était en
avril 2006 donc voilà on va fêter ça les
résidents 11e année dans deux mois
aujourd'hui j'ai une clientèle de 40
joueurs qui valent et de la pro a donc
c'est la première division française à
la pro b un petit peu nationale ubp
certains coachs de trois joueuses
donc j'ai des joueurs comme gars schalit
abuser les qui a été drafté par les
boston celtics cet été 16e choix de la
draft
c'est la deuxième plus grosse draft
française de l'histoire des garçons
comme charles kahudi international
français qui jouent en équipe de france
depuis 5 6 ans qui était aux jeux
olympiques cet été champion d'europe
avec eux les garçons comme jérémy
ainslie qui ai gagné un concours de
dunks all star game récemment dans des
garçons comme franz mekyna qui est le
jeune prospect du moment qui est appelé
à rejoindre la nba peut-être dans
quelques mois
voilà donc une clientèle qui est assez
varié quelques entraîneurs quelques
jours j'ai représenté pendant longtemps
emilie gomis
lorsqu'elle joue et qui était vice
championne olympique à londres
voilà voilà pour l'essentiel de la
clientèle donc une quarantaine de
joueurs et joueuses
voilà répartis sur l'europe les états
unis et la france
il ya deux façons de faire il ya on va
dire le démarchage classique de
présentation est entre guillemets de
deux présentations de projets voilà deux
d'essayer de leur vendre un projet qui
soit un projet global de représentation
de gestion de carrière et tous les à
côtés et moi aujourd'hui j'ai la chance
de pouvoir travailler on va dire à 90%
sur de la cooptation sur du relationnel
sur du réseau la plupart et voir la
quasi totalité de mes recrutements
seront à travers de certains de mes
joueurs de certains des entraîneurs que
je connais de différents acteurs du
milieu qui vont vous recommander ça
permet moi je pense d'avoir une barrière
de confiance qui est tout de suite
assez assez mises de côté si j'ai pu le
faire c'est que tout le monde peut le
faire je pense que voilà c'est la preuve
que tout est possible c'est vraiment
entre guillemets ou phrases créneau mais
mais voilà c'est quelque chose qui est
très élitiste
il ya énormément d'agents de joueurs en
france il ya un examen qui est mis en
place par la fédération française et le
ministère des sports
donc c'est quelque chose qui est au vert
je vais dire à tout le monde maintenant
voilà sûr je crois que la totalité des
120 agents qui sont licenciés je crois
qu'il ya une vingtaine d agences qui
travaillait régulièrement et on devait
être une dizaine je crois avoir on va
dire plus de 15 20 joueurs
donc voilà c'est quelque chose qui est
assez élitiste qui est très
concurrentiel et très très concurrentiel
mais voilà je pense qu'à force de
travail et passion parce que je pense
que le dénominateur commun de tous ces
gens là c'est la passion je pense que
c'est un métier qui est très chronophage
qui assez usant physiquement faut avoir
une véritable passion pour l'univers du
sport du basket en particulier pour
pouvoir durer dans ce milieu là oui